okay so welcome one and all
I'm mercury black the lunatik co-host of
sorting myself out I'm joined today by
Andrea Lewis from the YouTube channel
Andrea with the bangs and she's agreed
to assist me with my interrogation of
John and Pasha
now this usually goes best when you
start with the good cop so I'm gonna
hand this over to you Andrea the minute
you're not cooperating Jonathan I'm
stepping in so I all right Andrew we
should have come up with a secret signal
but okay so hello Jonathan Paige oh it's
good to meet everybody yes I am very
excited to be in this little cohort it's
my first little team up with another
channel so I am glad it's that is here
and guys now so okay
mercury mercury and I were speaking
yesterday and we got this idea of like
you know because symbolism the king's
court and the sub is their subject but
we rather than the king like we're tired
of hearing about him we're at least at
least in this impure purposes of this
this chat so we're I'm thinking about
like the Queen and then for Mercury's
sake I wish it was you saying this but I
am saying the the Jester slash fool so I
I am representing well Mercury's got his
misfits shirt on so it's perfect I'm the
queen but no but I I definitely in this
space represent the feminine anyway but
I would like to hear about it from you
because okay I've I've heard a lot from
say initially Jordan Peterson and then
from you and even when we talk about the
the margins it's we hear about monsters
who are some female but mostly male
and I'm I'm really interested in like
the feminine in in the different walks
of life so I'm gonna borrow from Game of
Thrones slash ancient Greece so we have
the maiden slash the virgin the mother
and then the Crone aka the three feets
so I'm that I'm kind of balling it I'm
gonna volume you forgot the Amazon the
Amazon is important oh okay oh oh right
she's da hey okay so there are women
especially for today today the Amazon is
all important because that's pretty much
the only character left pretty much well
then take it away
should we start there should we start
with it not a good idea to start with
the Amazon you finish let's start with
the first walks of life let's start with
the the maiden that is that okay well I
mean maybe we can talk about I mean
maybe we could talk about feminine
feminine characteristics the first thing
that's important to understand is that
we have to be careful when we talk about
these categories that we don't we don't
flatten the category with people and
that's really that's sometimes a
dangerous thing where we are all people
right so you're a person you're not you
are a woman you are feminine but you're
not only that and it's the same for me
so we symbolism is fractal so every
aspect of reality has both a masculine
ants and feminine aspect let's say right
so each person also but in a social
system then certain people are male and
then certain people are female and then
the males will have a more masculine
role and the females will have a more
feminine role it's a but it's really
important to be careful not to because
sometimes it can avoid it sometimes
becoming personal where people want it
to be personal you know it's like well I
don't I'm not like that or I don't feel
this or whatever so we all exist on
scales of these things like nobody is
only one aspect you know as a person
that's what important to talk about to
say first of all
a second of all so the notion of the
feminine is really the idea that
you could the first way to talk about it
would be to talk about the idea of space
right
the idea of space and an actor in space
and so the feminine is space and so that
means that when the feminine is
represented as the maiden then she
becomes the space that will motivate the
action of the hero right so she becomes
the she becomes the reason for the hero
to to advance and to make himself better
okay in that sense and well the idea of
the virgin first of all is also the
notion of pure potentiality so
untouched space you would say right
undefiled ah run into pure nature all
this kind of imagery is totally like
that's idea of a mother nature for
example is not it's not at all arbitrary
it makes complete sense that you have
the this kind of virgin natural world
which is untouched or unmodified not
modified something like that um and so
the maiden can have that role as well
and so it appears to the hero as
something extremely desirable because
it's something that you want to
concur in a way I mean it's it's kind of
this kind of it can sound bad when you
say it that way but it's the idea of
when you have the idea of conquering a
lady conquering your heart is better way
to say it you say conquering your heart
it sounds better but the idea is is that
you have this you want to join yourself
with this pure potential and and then
then the Virgin becomes the mother then
the relationship between the Virgin and
the mother then there's a transformation
where then the space the the space of
desire for action so let's say the hero
has this desire he see something which
entices him to want to act then then
when the union happens and it becomes
this face for the home so the house the
home the womb all this imagery of space
in order for the child to grow within
within the space and so that's usually
mostly most feminine symbolism will
manifest in that in that role let's say
but the thing that complicated about
feminine symbolism is that especially
when you think about a queen for example
is that this happens at every level of
reality so we have this idea of a
coupling that happens at every level of
reality and so there so people will
think oh man above woman below you know
like you see this I have an in Earth's
type of thing so that you can see that
there's a hierarchical relationship and
it's presented that way in the Bible and
didn't a lot of traditional stories but
that it happens because it happens at
every level it also means that at the
level of kingship there's a coupling
right and then at the level of society
there are couplings and then at the
level of your family there's a coupling
then in your own soul like in your own
self there's a coupling right so it just
it just kind of fractally fits itself
into each other and so so that's why you
can have a king and a queen and the king
is above you and the queen is above you
as well just like when you're a child
your mother is above you right your
mother is not the same the relationship
you have you're with your mother is not
the same that
will happen that will be with your wife
it's a very it's a different
relationship right there's a
relationship of seeing the feminine the
heavenly feminine you could call it
something like that and then the earthly
feminine or some some there's different
ways to say but that's a good way to
pronounce it and then there are figures
that join it all together realize
there's one figure the mother of God
Mary she joins all the images together
so she's wife she's virgin she's mother
she's she's she's all duh she's all the
images of the feminine kind of boiled
into one and so she's both the earth in
the sense of the make the matrix of
reality but she's also the heavenly
queen and she's the she's the Virgin but
she's also the the Queen in the sense
that she's actually crowned and joined
with her with her son which looks like a
in sexual thing but in terms of
symbolism in terms of ultimate symbolism
it makes sense if you try to bring to
bring the image of the feminine to one
figure it all has to kind of boil into
this one thing so that's the basic idea
of the famine Adam that makes sense
sometimes I feel like it does sin I like
that you gave the little like warning
like you oh I know that some people want
to think of it from a personal
perspective and and so we have to
understand that there are dichotomies
and and fractal-like bonds that goats
like you know showing this way in that
way and and it's not all one thing but I
absolutely is like personal like but
what's my hero's journey like like what
is I totally completely understand the
woman as home the woman as you you are
coming to find me like I understand that
and it does resonate at a really deep
level but at the same time I want a
purpose I want an aim and there is I can
I can tell you what the purpose of the
feminine is that you can't have one
without the other they were they're
complementary and so so you have the
image of the hero
who saves the princess from chaos let's
say who who separates the potentiality
that is useful from the potentiality
that's destructive okay that's usually
what when you save the virgin from the
dragon it's as if you're taking
potentially potentiality that's that's
useful you're separating the a good way
to say that which is very Mesopotamian
is you're separating the saltwater from
the freshwater so you have fresh water
which is useful and you have saltwater
which is deadly right and so that's this
idea of the so the hero comes and he
conquers the virgin he conquers the the
maiden okay now
the reason why he's conquering her is
because she is giving him focus
right he wouldn't be a hero without her
he wouldn't he wouldn't he wouldn't do
anything he would just sit around and
play video games and eat ain't he tips
and that's what he would do right
because the the feminine is is the the
frame of reality hmm
so okay an image the best image of the
feminine I think one of the best images
of is in Scripture you have Mary who at
the wedding of Cana this is one of the
most mysterious and amazing stories ever
told
so Mary there's this wedding and they
were alive wine and mary says to Christ
they ran out of wine so what she's doing
is she's presenting a problem she's
presenting a quest it's very little
it seems like a little quest but she's
presenting a quest she's she's framing
reality she's saying this is the frame
now you have to answer the question
here's the question you answer the
question
but that that question
that's a very very powerful thing I
don't think you can understand how
powerful that is there's there's a great
quote in My Big Fat Greek Wedding Saint
which looks very cliche or kind of silly
when you hear it but there everybody has
hurted where the woman says to her
daughter she says the man is the head of
the household but the woman is the neck
and it's a great quote it's an amazing
it's an amazing insight into the
feminine because what he's saying is the
woman will decide what the man looks
like looks at she will frame reality
she's gonna give him the frame and then
he's gonna answer but he's gonna answer
within that frame so when when Mary says
there's no wine
she's saying okay act reveal yourself
manifest the logos but manifest it in
this question right it would be silly
for it would be silly if she said
there's no wine and then Christ you know
changes stones into bread like why are
you changing stones into bread I said
there's no wine right that's the issue
that's the frame now act within that
frame okay and so that's why I mean
Jordan Peterson talks about this but you
have to you can understand at a very
deep level that is that's why the
stories of stories like like Beauty and
the Beast are about a a woman who tames
a wild man she gives him purpose she she
focuses his energy so that he can act
right and so it's so the idea would be
that the the feminine hero's journey is
to is to properly frame reality
that sounds very abstract but in
practice it can be very practical
practical right it can be extremely
practical because that's also what you
know that's also in a way what mothers
do with children right they create a
frame within which the children will act
and that frame is extremely important
that house that home all that is
extremely important but it's not limited
to the idea like I said of it's not
limited to the kind of cliche fifties
waif of making a home although it's part
of it but there is really this more
powerful image which is that without the
frame there's nothing nothing happens
manifests himself an answer only comes
for from a question okay
there's no question there's no speaking
no if there's no question there's no
there's no manifestation so okay does it
make sense to say that women so women
are the questions sorry not women I
guess we could say feminine or women
like there's a call-to-action there the
question yeah but it's a it's but it's
really important to understand that the
call to action is more than what you
think it's more than just a call to
action it's an actual framing of reality
it's deciding what's important okay it's
actually it's it's its relevance
realization in the way that John Greer
Vicky talks about it it's framing the
the discourse so framing the discourse
is he is comes before the discourse
oh I'm just thinking mother nature came
first well you can see you can see that
if you look at if you look at the
imagery in Scripture you have this sense
that so you have this sense that there
is this the the chaos or the matrix it's
it's like a
it is like desire in a way it's like
calling it's asking it's saying what so
what like what what what is going to
come of this like what is gonna happen
and so but that question is like I said
is that is the very primordial of Mary
at the wedding of Cana because she is
basically bringing Christ to - into his
mission and that's why when she says
there's no wine Christ answers my time
has not yet come which is just sounds
like the craziest answer to answer
because he's basically saying I'm not
ready to die but she's asking him about
wine like why is it that she's asking
him that saying does not wine and he's
saying hey wait a minute I'm not really
ready to die yet because he understands
that she is actually opening the door
for him and she's saying here's your
path take it this is it like I'm open
I'm opening the door you take you have
to take the path now oh okay
how many times have I read that I've
never seen what I've read it I've read
it a guy like I I say I have a degree in
Christian studies and Meyer and you've
never seen that in the end attack I've
I've never I've read it and I know the
story but I've never seen what he I've
never seen it like do you know what I
mean so he does the same Mary is an anti
Eve Eve Eve takes the Apple
what are you gonna do at him are you
gonna bite it or not he bites she
presents she presents possibility and he
takes the he takes the bait and but Mary
does the same Mary is basically and it's
exactly the same but it's it's in
Reverse because I Eve is leading Adam to
death and Mary is leading Christ to
death but as he says he says it's not my
time yet he's saying he knows it's gonna
lead him to death he knows he's gonna
die if he takes if he if he does this
right but there's there is salvation
waited right that's it that's the the
transformation of death into glory that
I'm always talking about and that's
what's happening in that story okay okay
I think you're like I've taken up so
much time mercury let's go to the margin
or we jump into the freak show just so
we're on the subject of the Divine
Feminine one thing Jonathan that you
might want to do I like a pop culture
reaction - for the purpose of outlining
some of what you were saying is masters
of the universe so I don't know if
you're familiar with that cartoon when
we were little but Kevin Smith is gonna
be bringing it back and so that it
become more culturally relevant soon but
the key thing is that Prince Adam his
lies around doing nothing as a waste of
potential he's got this tiger named
Cringer that is afraid of everything and
it's not until the sorceress who's
trapped within Castle Grayskull
protecting all the powers of the
universe so in other words dog and when
she finds Prince Adam she gives him the
sword that he holds up to say by the
power of Grayskull and so without her he
lies around napping and not doing
anything the King walk and to do and his
cat is a cow with the yeah and that's an
egg so defense that turns into battle
cat he turns into he-man which there's
nothing more masculine and then is
tasked with protecting her and all the
secrets of Castle Grayskull
so is this
man like ads in the he-man and Shera
like the because I'd collect vintage
toys I've got okay
merrily he mentalism all over the place
here but that may become bigger and
culture cuz Kevin Smith's continuing the
series and I would love to see you do a
video one day on the original masters of
the universe that Divine Feminine master
yeah when I was a kid there was that's
what I mean I remember watching that
when I was a kid that was four that was
it was playing so yes I do remember that
I don't I think I even had some figures
when I was a kid I think I did have the
he-man figure actually I'm pretty sure I
had a bunch as a kid but also now like
my kids have some vintage he-man okay
and I've got a bike my room is full of
old toys so I'm gone just a pile of
heman all over the fights you see you
see that in the story of King Arthur you
have a similar situation where where the
Lady of the lake she presents Arthur the
sword but it's a very very old story
right in the story of Gilgamesh we get
the same we get the same story we're
Anki do is presented as as a wild man in
the forest who lives with the animals
and you know who can barely speak can
barely do whatever and so the people of
Uruk send a prostitute to tame him
basically and so she kind of she kind of
seduces him and then in seducing him
then she also teaches him to to do to
dress and then to eat food and etc etc
and as he's doing that the animals start
to be afraid of him and then finally
kind of separates himself from nature
and until he's will he's ready to face
Gilgamesh in the in the duel but as I
recall he like curses her for waking him
up on his deathbed really I do okay okay
I've just I remember that I I just
listened to it there's a myths and
legends podcast called myths and legends
yes I like that
yeah I've been going through it like
crazy the past screams yeah yeah and so
he does the epic of gilgamesh and I mean
I just I just listen to it
and so like she but she literally comes
in the door be like oh really and of
course you know he's I mean he pulls an
atom it's the woman you gave me you know
but then but then you know she's just
doesn't straighten and he's okay maybe
it's a bad okay
all right after I know I'll have to
listen to that version on the podcast
according to this version I've like
really gone through the texts he does a
pretty good job he usually says it when
he goes astray like he says I changed
this or that when he tends to try to
stay pretty close to the he's actually
better and then first the first podcast
they were unbearable because he was
virtue signaling the whole time he was
always trying to show how he doesn't
agree with the characters and I think I
feel like he's gotten a lot better later
in the podcast where he stopped always
virtuous singling all the time because I
mean okay don't expect these stories to
fit politically correct ideology just
not you know just drop that before you
start telling those stories because
you're gonna apologize all the time I
just I do I do really like the way that
he he's like you know Zeus is gonna rape
like he always does like he's quite he
kind of has his little equips found a
way he waited to tell the story yeah I
think it's I do have woke a speaking of
the Greeks because I do have one
question that if we if you wouldn't mind
indulging me one last okay so regards to
the feminine okay
so Jonathan a couple weeks ago I
actually asked you on Twitter and I
talked to you about this and you
answered but I remember being confused
so I'm like forget to talk to him I'm
going to
I don't remember I am I know you've got
a lot of but okay
I asked about I thought it was odd that
of the three perpetual virgin goddesses
Hestia is one the goddess of the hearth
and I thought that was odd because the
hearth is the center of the home for
women well for everyone but like right
we're for women so that's why I actually
answered but I just you wonder why I
answer wait okay I remember not what I
answered okay I mean the idea is that so
the idea would be to understand the the
center right let's like the ideal
meeting of heaven and earth
if you ID if you idealize it you
actually have this idea that I don't
know how to explain it it's like - in
order to for the the feminine to be to
fully manifest everything that's that's
where the idea of virginity comes from
and so in Christianity we take it to the
extreme which is the Virgin Mother and
so she is perpetual virgin but she's
also a mother and so because of that
she's actually the mother of all
because she's she remains untouched you
could say so she remains the matrix
underneath the world right and so the
hearth which is the center so the so
though you can understand you can
understand masculine feminine there's
like heaven and earth as like two
categories like this but then when you
have a mountain let's say or you have a
center you have a category then you can
understand the category as as a center
and the center is made out of a
masculine and feminine element so let's
say in the temple or in the tabernacle
you have the seat the throne of God and
then you have the glory of God which
sits on the throne right if you look at
an icon of Christ and his mother you'll
see often he's sitting on her lap and
she is called the throne of wisdom right
and so she's she's the throne and he's
the glory of God on the throne right the
image of Christ on his mother's lap is
an image of the of the of the of the Ark
of the Covenant with the glory of God on
it and so the idea is that the center is
made out of the frame and the name or
the answer the question and the answer
the opening of space and the
manifestation of space okay so the
Virgin represents the potential of could
could go anywhere yeah and so yes
exactly
but you can so you can understand it as
so the ultimate feminine is unbound did
potential right so it's it's toboe it's
that it's it's Mara you know it's the
chaos at the the beginning of time right
it's the the the first this first
separation of having an earth right but
then there's also framed there's a
framed version so there's a universal
question which is is there gonna be
something like is there gonna be
something or nothing like you could say
that it's like the universal question is
there gonna be something or nothing and
then there are frame questions and then
those become more like the home
so you but you can represent it in its
virginal State because that's the frame
so you can say that want to be framed in
the eternal potential no but it's just
it's just different aspects of the
feminine and so potentiality
potentialities potentiality but there is
only one unbounded potentiality
there's only its the only one and then
there are different levels of
potentiality depending so like there's a
there's the potentiality within within
basketball right so the potentiality
within basketball is the frame of the
game and then within that frame then
certain things can happen but but a
pickup truck can't participate in a
basketball game that potential is not
available to the basketball game okay
right and so everything has a as a frame
as a limit has things which delimit its
reality and then within that reality the
discourse can occur so I mean I use
basketball but I could use any anything
right okay so you can represent that as
you can represent it as a virgin
if you want like it can be it can be a
way of manifesting that so the hearth
the center of the home so okay so you
have the heart and you have the fire
mm-hmm in the heart okay so you would
say that that Hestia is the goddess of
the hearth so she's the goddess of the
space in which the fire burns which
lights the the house but then also
becomes the center so so the identity
the frame of the identity and then the
identity the manifestation of the
identity or the particular of the
identity okay does that make more sense
yeah it just brings that like I'm like
oh yeah those divested virgins who had
to attend the fire for their lives like
they literally became what you're
describing figuratively yeah so an
example an example in Greece is that
there's a great example the example of
the of the what's her named Adele fee
Delphi Oh or so the Oracle at Delphi is
a perfect example
so the Oracle is a is a woman and so she
receives this like raw intuition right
she receives it's like raw we don't know
how she got it we don't know what she
did but she received this like raw
intuition and then she would say a bunch
of stuff but the people who came to ask
the Oracle for information would never
meet the Oracle they would meet the
priest
because the Oracle would speak to the
priests
and then the priest would would take
that potential and then would focus it
for an answer to give to that person
oh so the priest would always interpret
the Oracle for the for the for the the
person coming to ask the question so if
someone came with the question you there
would be two parts of it one would be
this like raw potential mixing up of the
super of knowledge or whatever and then
out of it would come a bunch of
associations and then the priest would
associate would would focus that to
answer the question the question ok so
he'd bring order from the chaos of her
Pateros reign chaos it's not pure chaos
it's okay it has a certain limit it's
just like so all forms of divination are
that so you you you take a bunch of
bones you know you throw the bones and
then they to fall so there's this like
chaotic weird thing that manifests some
intuition or some associations and then
but you need someone to interpret it
without it it's nothing right where do
you need both okay just like in
Scripture you have the tongues where
people say a bunch of stuff but in
Scripture it says if you don't have an
interpreter then it's pointless okay
nice more time trying to find all
million of analogies there no no no it
is no it's it's it's one of those things
where it makes sense all the things
you're saying and I just need to think
about it more it's also hard to think
it's hard it's hard for us to think that
way because we're not used to we're not
used to seeing the world that way and so
it's difficult sometimes for us to kind
of we can into like you can intuit it
but it's all of a sudden your rational
mind comes back and says well that's not
how things work absolutely
I feel very deprived of being from a
Protestant like background well for ever
with regards to the feminine like it's
just Mary like really yeah for sure sure
private ism is extremely masculine yeah
so she got really perfect for you yeah
but then in the Protestant space it's
like what yeah well not just Mary but
also the fact the reason the fact that
Protestants removed the the apocryphal
book they also removed the whole wisdom
of Solomon part which is which is which
is this kind of discussion with a witch
feels like it's God talking to his kind
of cosmic consort or like this idea of
this sacredness like Divine Feminine or
something okay we're not supposed to say
it that way but it's like there's
there's really is this thing happening
in wisdom of Solomon like there really
is this this relationship which which
got a lot of theologians into trouble
recently but it's still there's still
something there going on like there's
still something there
okay the margins mercury quickest way to
summarize to me cuz I assume you know
nothing about me right John
okay I was a Catholic altar boy as a
teenager got into punk and all that
independent film just before turning 27
I got hit by a bus
Oh rigored me being bipolar type one at
a very high setting of insanity complete
psychosis first time around all
revelation based into the mental
institution got out my first cycles were
three years long so two years of
suicidal depression I tried to put
myself together again another end of the
world scenario this time much more
twenty twelve related hmm anyway marched
into another sane asylum this time naked
bloody handcuffed wrists and ankles
after that I went into isolation I got a
house farm right near my parents I
didn't tell anyone where I was going the
first two years no phone no internet no
car never laughed couldn't see any
neighbors I just had all my supplies
dropped off as I came out of that I
encountered an archangel being aware
both of the psychological Richard
Dawkins perspective that this could all
be in my head and having the sub
personalities that were total believers
I interacted with the Archangel that way
where I examined it from every angle and
continuing to live basically in
isolation
it took me through a variety of training
I thought I was gonna live as a hermit
forever but at a certain point I was
asked to open myself up to the world of
that and the deal I made with God was
that I didn't want any of that messianic
crap to come up I didn't want to be
telling people what they should do with
their life so I said look I just want to
focus on figuring myself out and
continue my train if the world needs
anything from me have the world to ask
me directly and other than that I'll
worry about myself gradually people came
into my life needing help in one way or
another often people with serious mental
issues but it progressed to the point
where
certain point my Archangel I've come
across Jordan Peterson from his Jungian
depth psychology I'm not interested in
politics and I saw and that's how I
encountered Angela this is talk to
Jordan Peterson and my Archangel said
subscribe to that guy's channel you'll
be helping him out and I thought like
what am I supposed to do for Andrew and
you know my angels like nevermind just
subscribe well let you know and all of
Andrews stuff about diet and exercise
had very little interest to me I was
introduced as talks with you and such
but then one day he puts something up
comparing a quote from Peterson with a
quote from Alan Morra magic with B and
he was connecting the fact that they're
both saying look whether the gods are
inside you were outside you doesn't make
a difference they're [ __ ] real man
James seriously and when I saw that you
know my angel laughed and was like see
he needs to talk to you so I reached out
to Andrew and we became friends but also
I kind of mentored him a little bit and
he would ask my advice on the channel
eventually he asked me to belong the
channel and the response to the three
podcasts I'd done with him was a lot of
people asking me to start my own channel
and my angel said I didn't have to and I
was like screw that I'm not I don't
barely know how to use my computer so I
let that go but eventually when Andrew
wanted to stop doing his channel he
asked me to take it over and that time
my angel and the other people in my life
all said like yeah you should do this so
that's how I ended up getting involved
with sorting myself out and since then
like since the quarantine started cuz I
put out up I'd been very inactive over
like I have a yearly cycle so I died in
the fall and the winter in the crept
come alive every spring when quarantine
hit I went online and sort of asked the
community does anyone need that you know
I've been really and not that active but
you know my angel said to check with
everyone and since then that's exploded
I've been working full-time for the past
two months either doing content for the
channel hosting zoom of
and sort of facilitating group meetings
or my do private sessions with people
and they'll use me in from anything from
when you'd want to talk to a
psychologist abouts I know quite like
okay whatever angle the person Walla gee
I know other people come to me
essentially the way with shock like I
need a malfunctioning brain to run some
info through to get some you know more
random into the results and some people
use me sort of like a priest or an
emotional confidant I do a lot of
counseling people through suicide or
psychotic states look sorry not
counseling them through suicide I don't
teach people how to commit suicide I
mean I counseled them when they're
feeling I understood what you were
saying but you have been talking about
the monsters and the holy fools for
quite a while and you know what happens
when you talk about monsters too much
you end up face to face with why so most
of your discussions of the holy fool
have been explaining it to the normies
out there what advice do you have for
those of us who are dog headed men
finding themselves thrust into that
position um that's a really tough
question I mean they keep the bad cop
here and no it's okay the best of the
best thing that the best thing that lets
say the monsters can do in their role of
monsters we also have to be careful
again when I talk about these categories
we're not we're none of us are limited
to one category alright so when I talk
about categories I'm not talking about
people but the best thing that the their
monsters can can do is well they're two
they're two aspects one is to act as
guards and the other is to act as
bridges and so they they stand on the
the edge
and they're kind of usually they're not
seen well from the center right they're
seen as as freaks they're seen as kind
of just not kosher not right a little
bit off all of this is the perception of
the center but they're their positive
role can really be those two because
they're so close to the to the dark side
are so close to the bigger monsters then
they can on the one hand extend their
hand out and tame the bigger monsters
you could say it that way so they can
they can act as bridges to the outer
world and the other way is that they
also guard the inside from the bigger
monsters that don't want to detain you
know that that are that are threatening
to destroy you know um and so you can
understand that it's kind of like it's
like anything it's like anybody who has
you can think of it as someone who was
an alcoholic for example right and so
the someone who has touched that world
who's who's kind of been affected by
that world then will always be
can be a bridge you know to bring people
in you know but the thing is that that's
a positive aspect the negative aspect is
that the monster can also be a bridge
going out and can also pull people from
the inside towards the outside you know
the same thing with an out with a with
an alcoholic like someone who who has
those tendencies can pull people from
the inside into addiction we can pull
people out of addiction into you know a
more let's say ordered life so that's
what I would say that that's the two
positive roles that that the monsters
can play gargoyles and bridges st.
Christopher and the gargoyles well st.
Christopher is also a guard he's he's we
tend to represent him mostly as a bridge
in the sense that he carries Christ but
he's also a warrior he's also a warrior
Saint
make sense yeah that all made sense to
me um I think like you look missing
their firm if some other monsters
watching this is I've also found that
one thing I've been able to be of
service of is like one of my spiritual
practices is being a psycho having
learned how to be mindful I don't know
what that is what a psycho bomb a psycho
pump psycho pump yes okay yes yes I know
what that is the psycho pump like
crossing the river Styx or mercury okay
all across worlds and assisting others
in transit it's at a guard and a bridge
that's what that's what the psycho pump
does the psycho pump is the one who
crosses you over the waters like Saint
Christopher or and then and then he's
also the one who guards who prevents
those who aren't supposed to cross if
you're not supposed to cross you can't
get on the boat
he's not gonna let you why are you let
you through what we also do is sometimes
go into the underworld to bring people
up yeah this book that's when someone's
suicidal psychopomp because I've learned
I can manage mindfulness during extreme
suicidal states oh and I don't take
medication anymore all my magic and
spiritual nonsense is entirely how I
manage my condition and like all like I
don't even use psychologists or
therapists anymore either
but I can because I have no problem
going into hell anymore I've learned how
to be mindful and non-judgmental and
instead of saying God take this away
from me saying God let me understand why
I'm going through this and put it to use
I can go those places with people and a
lot of people have a little bit of the
monster in them and it's hard for them
to face that and if you can be a monster
who's okay with who you are
it will other people will open up to you
about things that they won't talk to
anyone else about again notice you're
not gonna judge them yeah also if you're
like me where you've learned how to be
mindful and how to manage your own
suicidal states and psychosis then
there's other people out there that we
can help in a way a psychologist can't
or a society and who's never been
through it and I never everything I do
isn't it's it's not instead of your
psychiatric help it's like if you're
taking all the help you can and you're
still completely losing your mind
I've got other techniques so those are
the other things I found the monster can
also do in this in society yeah yeah I
mean I it seems like that what you're
saying in these in terms of structure it
makes sense see that's you know you have
the whole image of the like I said the
ex-prisoner or the ex-alcoholic or the
someone who has been in the dark side
who might still like you said struggle
with some aspects of it but is enough
you know has it has been able to manage
their desires or to manage enough of it
so that they can they can be a guide for
those who are still kind of lost yeah
I'm no less crazy than I was sharing my
cycle it's just that unlike Peterson
slave the dragon
I just came dit and I know how I know
now what psychosis is for manias for I
know how to manage that and make it
productive and you got to do all your
shadow work and stuff because with the
spiritual you can connect to something
real but stuff up there so malleable
that if you're being run by all your
subconscious desires you just project
all your shadows into the energies and
here back your own [ __ ] so it's like
once you do all your own work and I
don't even know what to call it once
you've cleared out your Chado and
integrated yourself or whatever once
you've done that you can interact with
all of that so I can ride the ups and
downs now and I make productive use of
it and the more you do your work the
more clearly you can hear all the
[ __ ] imaginary friends not the saints
and angels at first you
you hear it but then it's like playing a
game of telephone
you completely mix it up before you tell
others and the more you do yourself work
the more clearly you can pass things on
while never losing track of the fact
that there's not a single one of us
telling the truth we're all filtering
what we learn from God or from the
outside world so if it's the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
like none of us have that so I'm always
staying mindful aware as well well but
I'll say like this is how I'm seeing
things but I'm sure it's not accurate
I'm just trying to be as accurate as I
can be
yeah and the truth the truth is is
complicated because the truth is also
based on the question it's based on the
frame of the situation that there is no
pure raw truth like there's only an
answer to a question so that's why like
you said you don't you always adjust the
answer to what is being asked and that
is not a lie if you're if you're doing
it forth rightly you're you're gauging
the reason for the question you're
gazing you're gauging all of that you
know and then you answer based on that
on which you gauge from the situation so
I think I think that makes sense
in terms of we talked about taming the
the dragon you know there are versions
of the st. George story worried that's
what he does that he doesn't kill the
dragon that he tamed the dragon he turns
him into like a pet dog
and he brings he brings him on a leash
into the village and then shows
everybody makes it do tricks
okay kind of stuff not subject up like
Aussie freaks
did you have anything you wanted
clarification I do I do it actually I
just say that little the the dragon
doing tricks reminds me of that the
latest Pixar onward I haven't seen they
have okay well they have a little dragon
dog does tricks just like what you said
um yeah I actually I would be really
interested for you to do a video on that
because there's a lot of questing in
that yeah yeah because it's magic well
whatever you you need to watch it
um but okay sorry your ordeal if you
want you think about these things that I
used to make video a lot of videos on
those kind of movies because my kids
would watch them and that's why I would
watch it because I don't actually this
is like my my dark secret is I actually
really don't watch a lot of movies like
very few I almost never watch movies and
so I usually watch them with the family
like I watch them with my kids and so
you'll see that like my the level of my
movie interpretations like they start
with like Moana and whatever and now
it's like like Avengers movies and like
15 so the movie that I watch well I mean
it does have like star-lord and you know
from green guardians of the galaxy and
it also has have to give you their kids
to watch because I don't want to they're
like yeah we're too old for that now I
don't know but like oh my like I mean my
husband and I took our kids and we we
were so they're they're the two older
ones I have an eight-year-old of six
year old and four year old they're all
boys hence my really my interest in the
feminine masculine dichotomy anything
because I'm surrounded by men but yeah
we went and my husband and I took the
older two and went and like we looked at
each other and were like like we were
like holding back the Torrens like the
tears it was it's really good it's an
old it actually feels like an older
Pixar movie okay I'm done with my pitch
I will move on but okay I just really so
yeah i'm it deals applause whatever they
always do but anyway okay so I I do have
a question with regards to monsters and
whatnot yes yes the mantra so so we I
have a question regarding the with with
tricksters those are on the outskirts
correct mm-hmm
okay yeah I I remember hearing a Jordan
Peterson mentioned this once and I
didn't really understand and I actually
I I think you've answered it and I
forgotten what your answer was because
you did a talk on the fool
I remember watching it but I don't I
remember the question I often forget the
answer so if you'll indulge me
well I is the trickster
I give way too long of a preface for
right why is it tricksters the the
precursor to the Messiah because when
I've been hearing a lot of these
trickster myths on myths and legends the
podcast and like you can't trust them I
mean you just watch The Avengers movies
like Loki's the worst you know Bucky
sometimes is the best but you know yeah
why is that the pre wise always the
trickster the precursor I think that's a
quote from young I mean I don't know
whether or not this is a systematic
pattern I'd have to really think about
it okay I do talk about the idea that in
in the upside down right when the world
is upside down then then the trickster
or the fool turns the world right-side
up because that's what the the fool does
the fool is always turning right the
fool is turning things so when the world
is right side up the fool is turning it
upside down mighty he's acting the fool
is always acting kind of upside down
right and so
that's that's mostly the way I
understand it so you could say that the
fool comes before the the messiah or the
trickster comes before the Messiah in a
way that he has to level the world so so
st. John the the for st. John the
Baptist right that's kind of he wasn't a
trickster but his role as the leveler
right so the trickster or the fool is
there to call out the the king right and
so that's what st. st. John does st.
John calls out Herod he says you know
you're doing this you're doing that
you're doing all these horrible things
and then that is one of the leveling
aspects of the making straight the ways
of the Lord right removing the current
structure
when it's corrupt
when I trickster can be useful I just
want to point out I'm not a trickster
for anyone who doesn't know me but my
thing is authenticity and I've taken
like a sacred vow of honesty so right
now you know all but I'm absolutely not
true yeah so it's like but you're right
it's not the same I'm on certain tricks
are not the same they're not they don't
have the same function that the
trickster really is the one who is who
is showing that the showing that the
pattern is wrong or undermining the
pattern that's what a trickster is
always doing a trickster is making you
think you've got something but there's
something else going on it's hip-hop
it's of the form it's it's hypocrisy
right
it's like he's showing that he so the
good trickster would be the one who by
his trickery he's showing that that the
pattern is his corrupt
he's left he's breaking it down by by by
undermining its you know the fact that
this limits you could say something like
that he it's he's showing he's showing
the okay so so there aren't that many
like pure tricksters in Scripture but
there are people who come close to it in
this for example Elijah is that's what
Elijah that's right so Elijah you know
he says all right so let's show let's
see let's see what God which God is
gonna answer they make your make your
you know put up your thing and let's
call the fire you know light here your
your sacrifice won't see which God
answers and then he's like you know and
he's laughing at the at the priests of
Baal and making fun of them and he's
like oh maybe your God is asleep you
know what's going on with what's
happening with that one of the one of
the most humoristic one of the funniest
scenes in the Bible is in is in the
light is Elijah when he makes fun of the
prophets of Baal because he's like you
know which is your God sleeping maybe
you shouldn't you should scream louder
and wake him up you know and so he's
showing that their system is false like
their system is is is saying something
but it's not connecting to reality it's
it's a form of you know it's not it's
not right
and so that's that's what I think st.
John I think that st. John the foreigner
was doing something like that as well
but he's not a he's not a trickster in
the end a more kind of mythological
sense you know right okay well I like
you say it's not the pure exact form and
iteration in every if you understand the
pattern you also don't necessarily need
it to be that you don't naturally
necessary you don't have to have it
for sure one of the tricksters in
Scripture is Jacob asked him like he
literally his name means trickster he's
told he's a snake like Jacob is a snake
for sure and it's a it's a funny it's
hard to figure out Jacob it's hard to
totally understand
like his he's also he's the he's the
name of he's the name of the pole people
like it's him he's the you know they're
named after him so it's a it's a it's a
weird it's a weird story yeah sir Jake
it was very strange well that's the one
like I I remember a couple years ago
when I like I watched I I binge-watched
Peterson's biblical lectures I mean you
know you just you have to you just have
to take him on and when he goes through
like the brothers the the what is it
it's a wrestling but like the the
brother well he uses like Thor and Loki
in the Avengers movies like the way that
they are portrayed you know he uses them
like having them be made brothers in the
in the movie but like the idea of like
the wrestling brothers trying to think
yeah and and Cain unable is so much more
clear-cut who's the good one and then
when you get into these twins it's not
so clear and he's that because it's like
progressing into life like life gets
more complicated or am I just reading
into that it's a
I mean I have my answer my answer is
that it's setting up Christ the whole
thing is setting up the story of Christ
you know and I mean biblical scholars
would tell me that I'm delusional to
think that but so the idea is that
you're it's like it's preparing its
preparing Edom you would say you know
it's it's like setting up the idea of
the of this foreigner which will then be
like let's say saved by by by Christ you
know and it's a it's a it's a funny it's
a funny situation and so it's like why
is it in Scripture that Abel is the one
that God loves it doesn't say it's very
vague it's very odd why why it's him and
but there is there is a sense in which
the first the first born or the first is
lost in the fall that's a way to see it
because because because Esau is Adam
he saw his edom that's his name his name
is Edom his name is Adam it's the same
word it's just it's the same thing it's
just been reworked means red he's the
same he's the same and so if you have
the sense that the first is lost and so
then then after the after the fall you
have this like loss of the head or loss
of the first and then you then it's
always the second or the last it's never
the first although in the law there's
this idea of the first like it's always
it's always it's never the first it's
always Joseph it's Jacob it's Isaac it's
always it's never the first is that it's
not just okay like I'm like in this not
to set up Christ and you're like yes yo
for sure I think it for sure and then so
Christ saves the firstborn that's what
Christ does well part of what he does
that's not all he does one of these
prices is the firstborn sorry I'm going
through all of my first Born's in the
Bible one of the things to cry one of
the functions that Christ has is to save
the firstborn
but are we not oh why he says Rome
that's why that's why Rome converts to
Christianity is because Christ is there
to save cane
wait how is Rome Kane what's the story
of Rome well it's the oh it's brothers
as well it's Romulus and Remus right so
Romulus kills Remus and found the city
yes
Cain kills Abel and founds a city
thanks to my myths and legends podcast
Ivers listen to that one and so it's not
it's not a surprise that so it's not a
surprise that the that the Jews view
Edom as Rome okay so in Jewish tradition
Rome Edom is Rome Rome is Edom when Jews
talk about Edom they're talking about
Rome so what does that mean is it the
first shall be last principle of the the
turning hierarchies on their heads is
that has to do with it has to do with
saving the world so Christ Christ Christ
restores the firstborn not just that but
that's part of what he does so that's
why Christ uses he uses imagery that is
based on agriculture he uses
agricultural images Christ joins the
bread and the wine with flesh and blood
so he takes Cain's sacrifice he takes
Abel's sacrifice and he joins them
together
why has it been there my whole life no I
don't know why people don't see it just
seems so obvious when you see it until
so that's one of the things that Christ
does is he is he is he but he doesn't
only do that so that's why he's also the
shepherd is also all of those other
images but he's also the sower the
Reaper the city he's also that you know
the the king of the New Jerusalem I'm
thinking of the prodigal son with
regards to the oldest as well and the
youngest and the oldest is the one left
out upset I think that's all I think
that's a little different like I think
that talking related to the idea of the
the lost sheep like the one of the
things that Christ is doing which is so
Christ Christ is connecting everything
together and so one of the things he
does is he goes to the margin see he's
always going to the edge he goes so it's
happening in every way possible you know
he speaks to prostitutes he he speaks to
tax collectors and I like the tax
collector one because all the like lefty
Christians they all love the margin
until the margins a collaborator no one
loves that no one likes a collaborator
but a collaborator is also a marginal
figure right so Christ goes to all the
margins and he connects to all the
margins and he and he puts his hand out
and he's like here's a way to come in
but here's I'm giving you a way to
continue to commit like all of you that
were lost they were outside I'm gonna
connect it all together and you can
participate in this and so that's what
that's what Christ that's one of the
things that Christ does so he goes to
get the lost sheep and so the idea in
the the prodigal son is more to do with
this moment you would say in in
Scripture where in this version actually
the the prodigal son is more like the
pagans he's closer to the pagans because
he's saying I'm gonna I'm gonna save
those that were that that were not
inside those that
those those that stopped following god
those that went their own way I'm gonna
bring them back so don't be resentful
because I'm going out there and I'm
gonna get all of them but don't they see
the Jews as the firstborn like as the
chosen people is that is that in this or
not really I don't think they see it I
don't think I mean I see they see
themselves with the chosen people I'm
not sure about the firstborn part I just
wanted it to work like I mean they're
not literally the children look as
Abel's dead but they're their
pastoralist
there so that was a little bit different
from the oldest and youngest situation
it's a little in that in that story
doesn't exactly have the same function
okay
okay well that's good to know because I
am like just getting into this symbolic
what you want if you want another little
hint at what I'm talking about like so
David King David is a hint at Christ as
well cuz King David he is a king mm-hmm
how why do they why all of a sudden
these nomadic people these like
Shepherds their house and they have a
king and they have a holy city like what
is going on like why do they have a
temple and a city right and so that's
why that's why there's a you can find it
on your own there's a place in scripture
where God says that that it says that
that David was red-headed yes ready then
he was he was Adam that he was ready
because he's Adam he's he's also
connecting he's also bringing back pain
a little bit like okay okay this leads
to more like so okay well I've heard you
talk about David is like a mirror mirror
to Christ or he's very nice for the
Christ that's for sure and I and I but I
don't I've not actually heard you it's
fully explained it so maybe I missed a
video or do I mean I've only talked
about it in the video they where I talk
about the fool
um I mean he he because he he David is
weird man David is that story that story
is he - he's not the first King he's the
second king yeah but he's he's the he's
like the it's the reason why he's the
second King is important because he's
the hidden King
he's like the the the hidden Messiah
right he's the he's the hidden King that
is king but no one knows he's King yet
and so then there are all these stories
about him kind of taking power from the
evil king or taking power from the king
of this world you would say but he does
it without revolution and so it's very
similar to Christ where Christ is going
to take he's going to conquer Rome
anybody who says Christ didn't conquer
Rome doesn't understand anything like
the Christ did conquer Rome it's funny
because the the Jews were thinking he's
not the Messiah cuz he didn't conquer
Rome but Christ did conquer all I'm
sorry he's it 300 years but he still
conquered Rome yeah you know but he did
it without a revolution right he did it
without without bloodshed you did it
without without refusing the authority
of the of the the power that's in place
um and so you could say that Saul is
like a fallen is like the fallen Cain
he's like the bad Cain okay so there is
that aspect icon of a bad aspect of that
right so he he's always trying to pin
down David he's trying to fix him right
with the Lance yes like Abel he's always
trying to do that and at first David is
the shepherd but then so it's like Cain
trying to kill Abel but then David is a
he's very close to Christ because he he
kind of then embodies he's a shepherd
and a king and he's also he brings all
these things together it's like David
that story is a wild story he kind of
he's starting to manifest all this but
that he brings in the different aspects
into one character well I'm thinking
even the priestly bit when he and
his men were hungry and they needed food
he said like why is it that David didn't
eat that why is it the damage can cause
so do something which is considered
sacrilege yes sorry yes right
yeah has to do with transgression in the
holy place and Christianity is all about
that I talked about this before
that's what Christ solves the the riddle
and he solved the riddle of David too
because David isn't totally right either
he doesn't totally get it right he's
still off but Christ solves it he brings
the scandal into the holy place but he
solves it by making it not a scandal at
the same time so it's like we take we
eat his body and his we drink his blood
what the heck we're not like we're
eating bread and drinking wine but it's
but it's the true body of Christ so it's
we're cannibals by the rowing it's
resolving this the problem its resolving
the scandal resolving everything I feel
like we're like all over the place
you're in the discussion sorry it's like
little bits that I picked up that I'm
like what is Jonathan mean by that huh
and I just I factored them away and then
they kind of just came out oh my all my
questions have been so I framed it we
did have a couple audience questions you
don't have time for it go for it I'm
having fun so this is good okay so I'm
also won't go back I know you were hit
hard by the flooding last year yeah I
don't know how like for me I was already
living off disability and for me the
pandemic like I was lucky in the flood
my farms up high and endemic it's been
the opposite of affecting me badly it
suddenly thrust me into a full-time job
that I mean it doesn't pay I'm still
living off disability but I'm wondering
you've got hit hard by the flood we also
hit hard by the pandemic or that's been
I've been surprised no I was really
expecting I was really getting ready
like in March I was thinking okay I need
to get ready for like my revenue to go
down
I need to get ready for all this to
happen and for some reason it didn't
happen yet and so I'm grateful then I
really I mean I've had people like I've
had patrons tell me like okay I can't
support you at night and like I'm like
you know thank you for everything you've
done already totally understand it but
then I've seen other people kind of come
up and I've seen the same with my with
my commissions for carving where some
people have said look I need to postpone
this I'm this is too uncertain I'm not
sure but I have so many orders in
advance that I'm not like I just haven't
seen I haven't seen it yet so I mean it
might come in the fall like I keep
thinking maybe the brunt of it's gonna
come when all of this kind of settles
and you know people really start to feel
the pinch but for now it's it's it's as
if we just kind of you know besides the
madness besides the insanity of being in
this this time and trying to understand
really what's happening and trying to
figure out what the play is like what's
being played you know what are the
stakes besides that I've been I've been
okay until a mental note then cuz I have
a lot of thoughts about one hand what
card the angels are playing right now
what do you think's going on at the
moment
I think we're in them in the time of
really of like massive chaos I really do
think we're on the edge of the world you
know I'm not and so I think that it's
not surprising to see what we're seeing
we're seeing excesses on all sides at
the same time excesses of of control
excesses of chaos excesses of you know
of mothering excesses of fathering
excesses of it's just everywhere like it
there's just we just move from one
access to the other and not only do we
move from one to the other but they flip
right so one week one faction is has a
discourse and the next week the same
faction at the opposite discourse and
has the discourse of their enemy and so
you have this like it's it's insane
it's a really it's enough to drive you
crazy if you're you know not careful
because it really is showing how much in
upheaval
our world is in terms of terms of
identity in terms of ideology and so I
think that I think that that's what's
going on and I'm not saying there is an
opportunity um I think there is an
opportunity but I don't know how long
that out we're doing is gonna last it
seems it might it might fade pretty fast
I just we'll see what's the opportunity
well the opportunity is that you can
reframe the world and so one of the
things that have been very pernicious
the modern let's say the modern
perspective on the world right from
let's say the late like from the
Renaissance the Enlightenment is the
kind of insipid
scientist of materialism that kind of
thinking has really been pernicious for
Christianity I think like very very
pernicious and post-modernism and let's
say the postmodern moment or the the
moment of upheaval this moment of chaos
and I'm flipping narratives and
everything is a moment where that
narrative is also coming apart and so so
I think that now the things that I'm
saying I think that I think that 50
years ago people would not have
understood anything of what I'm talking
about
I think they just wouldn't it would not
have been even possible to talk about
these things
whereas now because the frame is open
for is open to be grabbed so like we can
the frame is open for those that can
that can grasp it so I think that all of
a sudden people's intuitions are also
are also awakened
and that and because of that then they
they're more capable of understanding
the idea of a frame of reality itself
like because when I'm talking about when
I talk about symbolism that I'm saying
this is not I'm not talking about just
things I'm talking about the frame by
which things present themselves to you
and and I think that now people are
capable of perceiving it whereas we're
like I said whereas not that long ago
they just weren't so if there's an
opportunity okay but can I ask a
follow-up question like what are these
intuitions like can you break it down
exactly I know what you mean but I would
love it to be articulated you will the
intuitions the into intuitions are when
a particular meets a pattern that's
that's that's maybe the best way to see
it is when through through a particular
you encounter something that's beyond it
until you you see that this thing is
more than what is there
right so there's an event there's
something in your life there's a movie
there's a story and then all of a sudden
you can it's like you can see it's shiny
it's it's kind of it kind of glows or
not physically but it glows in a in a
epistemological sense like it it pops
out and it full it looks like it's full
of life and then you have that's when
you have an intuition of okay this is
there's more it's dangerous it's a
dangerous thing because that's what
that's what people who fall into kind of
wild crazy conspiracies that's also what
they have they have these intuitions but
because they don't have in my opinion
because they don't have the proper frame
then that intuition is limited to a
weird material causality and so they
have to admit so because they see
meaning in something they have to
imagine that someone somewhere put it
there maybe for them directly you know
that kind of weird stuff where it's like
someone is trying to talk someone is
communicating with me you know like
aliens are communicating with me because
I can see meaning in something like
Google is talking to me I've heard
people say that kind of stuff where it's
like I you know Google's it seems like
Google is actually answering things that
are too meaningful right because because
it's like they see this pattern and so
it's it can be dangerous but it's also
an opportunity to understand that the
world is is patterned yes i okay I just
did an interview last week with Sean
Carroll he's a he's like a physicist and
like a theoretical physicist and he was
telling me about how that's what they do
patterns that's what they're looking for
and I actually thought of you and I
wanted I actually I'm like I don't know
how to I didn't know how to frame a
question to him about symbolism and the
patterns there but I was like maybe
someday I will be like good enough in
how to how in the world do i frame a
question about patterns and symbolism to
a theoretical to did it you want me to
give you
an in for the next time you talk to a
physicist to see so yeah so one of the
problems with with scientists in general
is that they they're standing and they
look at the world and they tried to see
patterns in the world
okay now the proud one of the
difficulties and I think it's it's
actually kind of some some physicists
right now are you've seen the problem
but not a lot of them aren't so the
question is is there a pattern to the
way you look at the world so it's not
just the world that has a pattern you
also
our pattern and your mechanisms of
understanding are patterned hmm so it's
not like you're enough you're a weird
objective like completely neutral thing
that is looking at a pattern world you
are also pattern and your perception is
pattern and so then that's when
symbolism comes into comes into into
comes into the sphere so it's like does
do your thoughts have a pattern that you
can that are similar to the patterns
that you view in the cosmos to your does
your family have a pattern similar to
the patterns you view in the cosmos do
as all human activity is it also pattern
in a way similar well right yeah as as
the cosmic patterns hmm and so then it's
like and then it comes back so you have
to now like look back at yourself and
see that you're also that you're also
patterned yeah so anyways that's what
sorry said as within so without
yeah and that's the that's the that to
me is the key that's why I like I'm
that's why I'm attracted to and
connected to people like like John drove
a key or people who talk about emergence
and and the idea of content the problem
of consciousness and the relationship
between that and emergence all that
stuff I think is important in terms of
in terms of coming to the end of
scientism using science to to to to
flip science right mmm it's like let's
let's point science back at
consciousness and see what happens and
you're gonna be surprised it's gonna
look a lot more like religion all of a
sudden haven't you heard Donald Donald
Hoffman yeah yeah I have heard him
yeah there's somewhere that science is
flipping it and saying hey those
spiritual people telling you that
there's something more real than what
you see is scientifically a ballot idea
his work I find fascinating
yeah well it's because if once you try
to account for consciousness you know if
you try to brush it under the table
you're just being a complete idiot
because you can't brush under the table
the thing by which you're brushing it
under the table but you you just can't
you can't use the tool just you can't
use the tool of brushing to brush the
tool under the under the under the rug
like that doesn't work and so I think
they've mistaken the tool for themselves
they bonded with that tool so they don't
think they're using it exactly that's
what it is in but once you turn it back
and then you try it you start to look
back then all of a sudden yeah that's
when this weird desire to understand how
consciousness participates in emergence
you know and then and then that's that's
all so coming after Don Hoffman a lot of
a lot of ancient cosmologies you're not
gonna it's just sound it's stupid
anymore they're just not because the
pattern of something is not in the thing
you can't find it it's above it it's
transcends the thing so I think the
problem we've had is in part related to
Plato let's say or in part related to
that that that line is that you've tried
to see this these patterns just as
concepts let's say or as ideas right but
if we understand them as related more to
consciousness or will like in in
orthodoxy we talk about how the divine
essences are the wills of God in the
world hiding under under phenomena so
the the essences of things are actually
the Wills of God for those things the
purpose the hidden purpose and you know
of things is is a personal it's like it
it's more related to consciousness than
it's related to than to just concepts or
you know abstract abstracts so it's more
like intelligences so they end up that's
what they end up being the end up being
more like intelligences they end up
looking more like a hierarchy of angels
you know or a hierarchy of gods but the
hierarchy of angels is better because
it's the angels are submitted to the
highest whereas in the you know in the
Pantheon's there's it's just so messy
it's like just a huge mess myths and
legends people and so Shane's camera
died he was gonna ask the audience
question but um like we're still
recording and everything so he sent me a
couple the audience questions okay sure
Jonathan does symbolism take precedence
over what is metaphysically / logically
explainable and if so why now that's two
words that are quite a bit to put
together again I don't I I would I
wonder what he means by by
metaphysically and logically maybe try
them one at a time so does symbolism
take precedence over what is logically
explainable and if so why yeah well the
thing about symbolism and which I think
does take president just on logic is
that let's say I often talk about the
pattern right and then sometimes I talk
about what I call the meta pattern and
the meta pattern is both the pattern and
the breakdown of the pattern and so in
so that's why we that's why I'm able to
talk about things like the fringe like
the margin like the periphery because
that's also part of the pattern now the
problem with just logic is that it
doesn't account for the monsters doesn't
account for the freaks if you understand
how so if you so if you have the image
of the hierarchy but you also understand
the manner in which the hierarchy breaks
down and how the breakdown of the
hierarchy when I talk about also in a
non dual perspective the idea that the
breakdown of the hierarchy can actually
be turned into something which is more
like glory like so there's this like
death into glory and so it's like that
precedes logic because it contains also
the man in which logic fails and what
that also looks like so maybe that's the
best answer I can give I'd like to point
out when you said freak Andreea looked
at me like laughing in general you
happen to be in the general direction so
I just said I think that like I think of
Kirk and Spock and how Kirk is the
captain not Spock there's a reason for
that right something to this Jonathan
your Kirk I suppose yes Kirk is supposed
to supposed to be the bridge between
Spock and bones like that's supposed to
be his role it's supposed to be the one
that unites the like the the raw
emotional guy and the hyper-rational get
it we got to please the
the Nerds which I am one you are one of
them I watched I watched Star Trek next
generation of the team I was okay I'm
more that I yeah I'm more of a Picard
girl yeah I like okay sorry about okay
another another audience question if you
have one go for it
okay so the next one and yeah Shane if
you have more audience questions that I
get if you send them but Shane decided
to ask one himself next so he said first
of all love your work
so interest doing powerful and he says
when you talked earlier about grasping
for the frame can you give an example of
how that would manifest in someone's
life and in the larger world I mean
would the idea is to understand your
your place that can sound horrible you
say it that way like know your place
no it's much better to know your place
yes but yeah especially as a monster
where you're nice and stick to it and
stick to your plate
so I think that it has to do it has to
do with that it has to do with with
properly estimating the potential that
you have right properly estimating the
the actual actual potentiality so it
means not aiming end up so you end up
not aiming too high you end up not
aiming too low right so I mean you meet
people who who struggle to do that in
every single way like you meet the guy
who who says he can't meet a girl but
the only reason is because he's always
aiming out of his league like and that
sounds like a horrible way but it trying
to find a very practical manner in which
in which like that can happen right and
you meet you so the idea would be took
to to properly understand your your
possibility right
so the mystery the mystery of
Christianity this is one of the
mysteries of Christianity is that there
it has to do with this idea of the
Virgin Mother actually that's to do it
side this idea of virgin virginity which
is that this the highest Saints are the
ones who actually let's say go the
lowest in terms of let's say self-denial
something like that where they actually
eliminate they actually go like they
actually eliminate their frame all the
frames right until they're nothing and
then then they're illumined because they
they've eliminated all the worldly
trappings right they've eliminated all
the all the hierarchies so there's
nothing I don't want to I want to
clarify there's nothing wrong with the
they're not necessarily anything wrong
with the the natural social hierarchies
but those who are able to divest
themselves from those are the ones who
reached the end of reaching the highest
but in terms of the natural just regular
hierarchies is similar right it's like a
few understanding you know it there's
nothing wrong we actually it's funny
because there is a problem with that
right now today which is that we have a
system which only values one tie almost
only values one type of success and so
there was a time in history where you
were born into a family of bakers and
that was your world and that was awesome
and it was fine to be a baker and it was
fine to like to become that and you
didn't have to there wasn't this idea
that if you don't go to college somehow
you're your you know your suspect or
whatever you know and so that's it we've
struggle with that in the past few
generations where the capacity we want
everybody to be equal rather than say
you know this person would make a great
you know like a great construction
worker and that's awesome like doing man
not going to like knock it out you know
then this person would make a great
lawyer it's like yeah that's it that's
your frame like that's your possibility
take it there you know rather than
making everything everybody the same
which is just baloney the other thing
we've done now that you know child
growing up in the family of Baker's
wouldn't have had is we over glorify
certain positions so that child growing
up knowing they're gonna be a baker
doesn't feel all that adolescent
pressure to be a rock star or a baby
star to look like Brad Pitt and be the
smartest Sam Harris and yeah I think in
one way that especially now that anyone
can suddenly be a star way it's almost
you tuber is yeah and it can be now just
you don't need to be exceptional in any
way that except that you can suddenly be
famous
it's this weird pressure everyone feels
to be exceptional that somehow you're
less than that rock star yeah whereas
it's just not the case we're glorifying
certain things needlessly while
degrading other things that have so much
value yep sure Jesus was a carpenter so
other aims but he had a different name
than the typical but still start from
there you know Jesus was a carpenter
because he was there to save king who is
the carpenter like who is the
technically who's the technical person
in Genesis like is that one of the
things that his his descendents the
descendants of Cain are the are the ones
whose to create metallurgy who make
cities who make weapons oh yeah well I
just you know there's that song Jesus
was a cross maker but you're like oh no
no there's a lot of them that we talked
about before can we I have a question
but I'm probably gonna I'm probably okay
I'm gonna finish soon though guys all
right okay all right okay
okay tonight wait should I ask the
question or show you
you the last question and then okay okay
how did you learn all of this I think
I'd probably mentioned this before so it
part of it is my brother material who
wrote a book called the language of
creation recently but when we were in
our 20s we both developed this intuition
at the same time and we both kind of
were ravenous in our reading and our
curiosity and in our discussions I mean
it was just crazy it was non-stop for
several years and and that's how it
started really you know and I mean part
of it was also just reading certain
books which triggered a transformation
and then discovering traditional
Christianity and the truth is like I
can't totally account for the intuition
like I can't tell you why for some
reason I I can see this path these
patterns I it's a gift from God I don't
know whatever I don't totally know but
for sure at some point in my life I I my
brother and I we were able to to kind of
perceive these patterns brothers mm-hmm
cool there's that but you works together
so it's going back to the conversation
let's go back to the same spot all right
guys I think I think I'm gonna go
because this it I usually I rarely go
for this long when conversation but it's
fun as a lot of fun I really enjoyed it
yeah thank you so much this is very
fruitful
it was nice to meet you and send me a
link to the to the talk once you guys
put it up all right good night everybody
the audience
[Music]